inside the American Museum of Natural
History in New York is this enormous
iron meteorite it crashed into Earth
here in Northwest Greenland around
10,000 years ago as a piece of space
debris and for centuries was used to
make metal tipped tools and weapons by a
small tribe of indigenous greenlanders
the inquit until an American Explorer
seeking fame and fortune dragged it
across the Arctic and sailed it to New
York to sell to the
museum but this giant piece of iron
isn't the only thing brought here on
that ship in
1897 six inquit came too after being
told they'd return home to the Arctic
within the year rich with weapons and
tools if they agreed to be studied by
the museum most of them wouldn't make it
back it's a story of false promises big
Ambitions and one small boy who would
grow up to challenge the Museum that
took everything from
him
for centuries of human history pretty
much the only way to get iron was if it
crashed into Earth from space in the
form of
meteorites like here where 19 iron
pieces including this dagger were found
in Tuten Common's tomb which was sealed
centuries before smelting technology
developed in Egypt ancient Egyptians
even had a hieroglyphic symbol for
meteoric iron which translates literally
to metal of the
sky indigenous groups in this part of
the world were used using meteoric iron
to like the inquit sometimes called
polar Inu who make up the northernmost
band of Inu the ancestors of the Ino
first came to this part of Greenland
around 1,000 ad and the Chance existence
of meteoric iron here was a crucial part
of making this region inhabitable for
humans at all this area north of the
Arctic Circle has always been harsh and
extremely remote but the little Ice Age
which spanned from the 15th through
early 19th century froze ocean access to
this region making it even harder to
reach the inquit lived in Virtual
isolation for centuries until an
expedition led by British Explorer John
Ross arrived in 1818 and came
ashore when he saw the iron tipped
knives Spears and harpoons Ross assumed
at first that the metal must have washed
up from a shipwreck until the inquit
told him it came from a nearby
Mountain Ross guessed that this Iron
Mountain must be a crashed iron
meteorite bad weather prevent to the
Expedition from finding the Iron
Mountain which Ross later described as
the most important mineral production of
this country this was the beginning of
an increase in trade with European
explorers as Northern Expeditions
continued here throughout the 1800s
several of which tried to find the
meteorite but never could by the 1890s
the inquit had become accustomed to
trading with foreign ships for
manufactured goods metal tools and
weapons and relied Less on the meteorite
as their sole source of iron which is
how an American Explorer hungry for Fame
and Fortune Justified his decision to
take
it at this time the Foreigner the inquit
interacted with the most was this man
Robert Peri he had come to this remote
part of Northwest Greenland with one
goal in mind reaching the North Pole
Peri was part of an era of European and
American exploration in the late 19th
century obsessed with the parts of the
map not yet reached by white people and
in the case of the North and South Pole
not known to have been reached by hum at
all he's considered to be the first
non-inuit to study greenlandic Inuit
culture and survival methods and
throughout his years of exploring the
Arctic funded by his wealthy family and
by groups like The National Geographic
society and Brooklyn Institute of Arts
and Sciences now known as the Brooklyn
Museum the Inuit taught Peri how to
survive Arctic conditions and how to
travel over the ice using sled dogs they
also worked as expert guides Hunters Dog
Handlers and laborers during his Arctic
Expeditions from a tra TR perspective
the relationship was beneficial to the
Ino but it was much more enriching for
Peri while the Ino got resources like
guns household items and metal tools
from Peri Peri got Furs and ivory from
the Ino which along with other cultural
artifacts he would bring back to New
York and sell to support his efforts to
reach the North Pole when Pi's 1894
Arctic Expedition failed he knew he had
to come home with something to keep his
backers
interested and he knew from stories
going back to John Ross in 1818 that the
inquit had access to a rare iron
meteorite maybe a big one so in exchange
for a gun to an Inman who said he knew
the location of the Iron Mountain Peri
was led right to it a lot of this
history has been lost to time but what
historians do know is that Peri didn't
ask permission for what he did
[Music]
next after a mostly inquit crew
excavated two fragments of the meteorite
found here and dragged them to per ship
using rope and wood rollers Peri learned
of a third much larger fragment on this
nearby Island too heavy to take on his
ship it would take multiple attempts
over the next couple of years returning
to Greenland with a much bigger ship and
specialized equipment including heavy
duty Jacks and even a custombuilt
railway to excavate and then drag this
largest meteorite across the Arctic
landscape to the edge of the island and
finally load the most expensive resource
Peri ever extracted from the Arctic onto
his ship Bound for New York careful to
frame his interactions with the Inu as
nothing but good-hearted and without
coercion or exploitation per
orchestrated a few images about his
removal of the tribe's local source of
iron by staging this scene recreating
the as he put it ancient practice of
mining the meteorite for metal and
captioning this photo of the inquit who
moved it for him as a farewell to the
savic saw the meteorite who Peri later
wrote happily did all they could to put
into my possession the Iron Mountain of
their forefathers but the meteorite
wasn't all Peri took from the tribe to
impress his backers in New York because
an assistant curator for the American
Museum of Natural History had asked a
special request of Peri that he bring
back in a Nook to be studied at the
Museum per convinced six inquit to come
with him a respected Hunter and key
provider in the tribe named nutak who
brought his wife atanga and their
12-year-old daughter aak a young man
named Wisa kasak and kisuk a another
skilled Hunter who lost his wife to an
epidemic brought on by one of Pi's
earlier Expeditions who brought with him
his seven-year-old son manik per didn't
just promise to compensate the group
handsomely for their Journey he also
assured them they'd be taken care of by
the museum for their entire stay in New
York but that's not what
happened when per ship with the giant
meteorite and six inquit on board
arrived in the Brooklyn Navy yard in
October 1897 it stirred up a lot of
excitement 20,000 people paid to board
the ship and see the people and
meteorite Peri had brought back which he
pocketed to fund his further Expeditions
and then left on a lecture tour
promoting his latest thrilling
adventures in Greenland leaving the
inquit in New York to be studied at the
American Museum of Natural History where
they were initially forced to live in a
damp hot basement inside the museum
within days of exposure to the warmer
climate and with no immunity from
American diseases they were all
hospitalized with respiratory
infections mik's father kisuk was the
first to Die the museum told Minik they
buried kisuk but that wasn't true kook's
body was dissected and his remains were
stored inside the museum for further
study photos of his brain appeared in
this 1901 scientific report soon after
kook's death atangana nukak and their
daughter aak died of disease
too and Wisa kasak asked to be sent back
to Greenland which left only manck alone
and the only ino in all of New York City
by
1899 just 9 years old manic had lost all
contact with peri at this point the
Explorer never came back for the people
he convinced to come to New York and
sold their meteorites to the museum for
$40,000 an equivalent of more than a
million dollar today it took a few years
for the museum to find a way to remove
the meteorite from the Brooklyn Navy
Yard which they finally did in 1905
before and just like in the Arctic
carefully dragged it through the streets
of New York on wood rollers and then a
giant truck pulled by a team of horses
all the way to the American Museum of
Natural History where it became a
Prestige item and major attraction for
the museum there's no record that Peri
ever shared the fortune he got from the
meteorite with manck the boy he brought
to the museum and then
abandoned after his father died manck
was taken in by a museum official named
William Wallace and grew up in New York
City under Wallace's care he forgot his
native language Eno tun and started
going by the name man Wallace eventually
his foster family fell on hard times and
now impoverished a teenaged manik
started asking questions about his
father kisuk and though it's somewhat
unclear how discovered the truth that
the officials from the museum had lied
to him and his father's body had been
desecrated without mik's knowledge and
was inside the museum supposedly in the
name of science starting in 1907 mck
took to newspapers to tell his story and
publicly pleaded that the museum return
his father's remains so he could give
him a proper burial they ignored him the
following year he called on Peri to help
him leave New York and send him to his
home in Greenland Peri said there was no
room on his ship at least not until 1909
when there was suddenly a spot for manck
on one of Pi's ships Bound for Greenland
it was right around the time Peri
claimed that his recent Arctic
Expedition was the first to reach the
North Pole and manck was writing in
American newspapers about how Peri
treated his people when he was a boy
including taking the meteorite which
Peri put aboard his steamer and took
from my poor people I can never forgive
Peri and I hope to see him to show him
the wreck he has caused a few months
before per returned to the US from his
final Arctic Expedition manck was on a
ship back to Greenland before manic left
he wrote the biggest regret he had about
leaving America that I must return home
alone leaving the body of my father who
was taken from me a martyr to the
coldblooded scientific study of your
people when manck got home to Greenland
he needed to relearn his native language
and inquit Customs like hunting kaying
and dog handling he'd only been around 7
years old when Peri took him to the US
after all he eventually returned to the
US in 1916 working as a lumberjack in
New Hampshire he died there 2 years
later one of the millions of victims of
the 1918 pandemic the museum never
answered his repeated calls to return
his father's remains they kept the
bodies of all four of the inquit who
died in their care for almost a century
until New appeals were made by author
Ken Harper who had published give me my
father's body a deeply researched book
about manck in 1986 the museum finally
gave in to mounting pressure and
returned the remains of kisuk nikak
atangana and a to Greenland in
1993 when we reached out to the American
Museum of Natural History for comment
they acknowledged that their role in ki
bringing Manic and the five other inquit
to New York in 1897 included a series of
unethical and unjustifiable actions
especially the morally abhorent Act of
misleading manik and refusing to return
his father's remains only in October
2023 did the museum finally began to
reckon with the more than 12,000 human
remains it kept going back to the 1800s
and committed to removing all human
remains from its display cases but the
meteorite Peri took is still there it
remains a signature exhibit of the
American Museum of Natural History which
the museum has described as the largest
meteorite in
captivity a plaque displayed in front of
the meteorite includes a passing mention
that it was brought to the museum by
American Explorer Robert Peri but
nowhere in this room will you find a
mention or a photo of manik or kisuk or
any of the six people that Peri left at
the
Museum